imagine a mad scientist who's trying to
create an artificial being
indistinguishable from a human and early
in the development of this machine he
asks you for help testing the mind and
so he confined the mind to a box
the only way it can interact with the
world is by reading input messages and
responding by printing output messages
and he presents you with the following
challenge he shows you two identical
boxes the other is connected to a human
being typing the output messages and you
are allowed to ask the boxes any
sequence of questions you can imagine do
you think you could distinguish the
machine from the human what would you
ask new automatic calculator at Harvard
University intricate problems in
mathematics put through the machine and
coded form on tape are accurately solved
into my new fraction of the time
required for human calculation in the
first half of the 20th century
general-purpose computers were only just
emerging but speculations were swirling
about what would or wouldn't be possible
in the near future with robots or
intelligent machines it was a time when
many human tasks were quickly being
swallowed up by machines people feared
powerful industrialists would soon be
supported by great machines machines
which could do anything resulting in a
class of poor laborers who would simply
toil away to power the machines
in 1950 Alan Turing wanted to ground
these speculations about machine
intelligence using a scientific approach
known as a Turing test where a
successful pass would mean unequivocally
that whatever is in the box could be
identified as intelligent and to this
day no machine has been able to
accurately mimic conversation over long
periods of time historically the concept
of knowledge and answering questions
have always been intertwined across many
cultures there is a deep-rooted belief
that the source of all knowledge comes
from a higher power and one way to
access knowledge from a higher power is
by posing questions and waiting for a
sign
in ancient Greece citizens could take
their toughest questions usually key
decisions in social and political life
to a medium who would enter a special
location known as an Oracle for example
the medium Pythia from Delfy would enter
the sanctuary of Apollo ask her question
fall into a trance-like State and emerge
with the answer
touring reference to this history with
his imaginary Oracle machine inside his
Oracle machine would be access to an
Oracle database a database which
contained all answers to all questions
in one column there is a list of all
possible sentences think of this as our
question column and many of these
sentences would be meaningless but every
question you can think of is in this
book and in a second column the
corresponding answers if a machine had
this Oracle database it would be able to
answer any question but could Touring's
Oracle machine exist in the physical
world
well the question column alone would
contain every possible combination of
English words even if we limit ourselves
to all possible 12 word sequences that
results in 10 to the power of 72
different sentences now even if you
shrunk every letter down to the size of
an atom you would still end up with a
book larger than the size of the visible
universe
so the Oracle database cannot exist when
we store knowledge this way by simply
memorizing facts we call this the
clarity of knowledge for instance
memorizing your multiplication tables is
declarative knowledge music boxes can be
said to know a song declaratively the
music role declares each note this works
well with small numbers
or short songs but as the numbers get
larger songs get longer you'll
eventually run out of memory so if a
machine only knows declaratively meaning
it memorizes everything then there is a
very real physical limitation space
so if a machine is passing a Turing test
we know it can't simply be memorizing
all possible answers it must be taking
advantage of another kind of knowledge
it must know how to know meaning it goes
through a process to get an answer for
example knowing the rules of
multiplication or knowing how to compose
new music and this kind of knowledge
known as procedural knowledge is the
focus of computer science how do things
become known
you